foreign
people should look this name up
how has your
time with Ayan changed how you view
Western philosophy maybe even View
the world or reality
per se I have to imagine I mean just
given her life's experience her
trajectory that is so difficult for
either well I'll speak for myself for me
too
Envision in uh
in any experiential way right
how was your time with her affected
how you view things I know that's a very
broad question but I'm going to leave it
Broad
anybody who hasn't read
one of my wife's books should do
something about that I on her see Ali
Infidel is a pretty good place to start
that's her life story or early life
story which gives you a sense of what it
was to grow up as a girl in Islam in
Somalia to live in Saudi Arabia to live
in Kenya to experience radicalization to
be a member of the Muslim Brotherhood
and then to go to the Netherlands to
escape an arranged marriage
to gradually be exposed to Western
freedoms to begin to question
Faith eventually to lose that faith
to become embroiled in the controversies
that followed 9 11.
to become a national figure in the
Netherlands A Member of Parliament and
to be the target of of a fatwa of death
threats all of this is in there and it's
an extraordinary story
I've learned that the story there which
is
startling and memorable in many ways
is the tip of an iceberg a very
deep trauma
I think that's the only way to to
describe it and
we're still kind of
learning about that and learning how to
deal with it
so
for somebody like me who led a happy
life in a loving family where I was
given every encouragement
it's
tumbling to
think of a life so different so much
harder
and to realize that that's the life of
millions and millions of of girls all
over the world so that's point one point
two is and I dedicated the book
civilization to Ayan for this reason
we take for granted the freedoms that
we are given at Birth
and it's very hard not to take them for
granted if you grew up with the freedom
of speech and political Freedom the
freedom to organize the freedom of
Association all of those freedoms
but when you
when you get to know and love somebody
who didn't have those things and had to
be persuaded by experience of their
value then you see things in a different
light and I I learned more about the
value of the Enlightenment from my arm
than I I could have learned from any
other source
and that's partly why civilizations
dedicated to her because you've got to
see the benefits of a free Society
with the eyes of somebody who's lived
under um freedom
with all the Discrimination the
handicaps of
being a girl in a strictly Muslim
Society fully to appreciate them
that's second the recommendation
on the read this story is is really
Beyond remarkable that's another
statement and
he mentioned the fatwa how do you both
relate to safety and fear
how do you think about
how much weight to give to fear of what
could happen and I ask especially in
light of
the not so distant attack on Salman
Rushdie as an example right it's it's
not like
fatwas are just forgotten it would seem
I mean I know there's a lot of coverage
around that many different takes but how
do you think about living life
and how much weight to give to fear what
could happen versus
versus other factors
but I would speak for ION it would be
untrue for me to claim that she
doesn't feel fear yeah the um
the attack on Solomon Rushdie was
a heavy blow
for us because it was a reminder that
these death threats don't have expiry
dates there's no statute of limitations
but fear I'll answer on my
own behalf is not a factor
I don't fear these people
and
I credit that to
a Scottish upbringing
my grandfather's faced far greater peril
in the world wars
uh my
father's father served on the Western
Front in one of the Highland regiments
as a as a teenager
and my mother's father was in Burma with
the Royal Air Force fighting the
Japanese
they they had reasons
to feel fear I don't and
I have a complete contempt for
terrorists
that is not fake
I moved to United States after 9 11
because
I was supposed to give us a lecture at
NYU on I think it was
9 12.
and of course I never gave that lecture
couldn't fly
but it kind of made my mind up to move
to the US and to take a job at NYU which
is what I did I resigned from Oxford
shortly after
9 11. that's that's definitely wasn't I
don't think I thought it through quite
at the time but it was undoubtedly the
the Scottish impulse to March towards
the sound of gunfire
and ever since I've known Ayan
I've felt a powerful obligation to
protect her and make sure that she is
kept safe
but
never fear
because
historically we Face many dangers
one can see that the world is much less
dangerous than it was in many respects
another respects more dangerous than
it's ever been
they didn't have to worry about nuclear
war the risks of
catastrophe are in some ways elevated by
the advance of Science and in other ways
science is reducing our our
vulnerability extending our lifespans
giving us a shot even if we're diagnosed
with cancer
and I keep telling her and others the
dangers
that we Face includes terrorists but the
probability
is probably higher that we have an
automobile accident or one of us gets
diagnosed with cancer so be not afraid
and
the culture which I love about my part
of the world the culture of Scotland is
we don't we don't feel fear
you can do anything to us but you can
actually frighten us and if you're
brought up with that
if that sort of really drummed into you
that's a great source of
of strength
because one fears
odd things
I've always been more afraid of of
losing my reputation or my honor than
losing my life
but the things that the terrorists want
to induce the kind of fear they want to
induce that is entirely foreign to me
and I defy them and I despise them
and I will use everything I can do
to thwart them because ultimately
their threat is a
it's a threat that you can thwart
Solomon Rusty made a terrible mistake in
announcing that he was dispensing with
security and saying at the time he
published his last book I need to live
my life I said at the time that was a
mistake
and it was
that is not our approach
but no fear no way